this Memorial Day weekend marks the end
of the holy month of Ramadan during
Ramadan Muslims fast every day from
sunrise until sunset and then gather for
the iftar or the breaking of the fast
but this year has looked very different
we asked five Muslim Americans to show
us what Ramadan has been like during the
pandemic they live all over the US and
include a religious teacher a bakery
owner and a doctor who is treating
coronavirus patients a week to have
support which is a vaccine during my mom
this year has definitely been extremely
difficult in comparison to previous
years I don't take the elevators at work
because I am a little paranoid about
being in small spaces with other people
I'm walking up and down several flights
of stairs wearing an n95 mask not having
anything to eat or drink in several
hours it's exhausting I've got some
battle wounds if there's other doctors
that are not fastened during this time
it's completely understandable for me
remember bond is a very personal thing
well you get from fasting it's such a
unique and Rost sense of connection with
God when you strip away the needs of
eating and drinking for a set amount of
hours it really causes you to reflect on
your priorities in life the thing that I
missed most about past Ramadan's Creek
ovid is the ability to stand in front of
people and lead the nightly prayers
is this her gonna rush it's a certain
energy you get and now this screen in
the zoom and the hangouts and the
different platforms that we're using to
connect with people that that that
adjustment is different but now we're
able to connect with so many people from
different places different times or
different levels
[Music]
normal Sheila be free would be filled
with people especially before it's tired
right after lots of big groups families
we're hoping next year everything will
go back to normal and we'll get that
social closeness back it's been very
difficult this from Oakland to not have
the opportunity to physically gather
with the community
community is such an enormous part of
the Ramadan experience that's so
critical for feeling the spiritual
connection so you'll see now that there
are a lot more virtual if dollars where
people are breaching fast together
waiting people this is a group of people
who I didn't know three weeks ago and
that's extraordinary who see your bread
I was raised Roman Catholic and I
converted to Islam I'm the only Muslim
in my household so you know when I pray
or fast it's just me but now with these
people even though it's on a zoom call
it feels like they're sitting around the
table with me you've been cheating on us
with a different group of people it's
something that I'll always remember from
this Ramadan when we're isolated the
last thing we expect to do is make new
friends I mean how does that happen
we try to make it work with my family we
would sit 20 feet away from our family
this is still a special time for us
because we're able to remain connected
in our own way despite these
unforeseeable circumstances
Thank You producer Nam Sadiq and Camille
Douglas for that beautiful piece I love
when we can connect people in this way
this is what coronavirus does it it's
changed everything the way we worship
the way we pray and even making new
friends I like that beautifully done
anything yeah it's so interesting it's
so interesting what zoom has done and
how people are using it and this chance
that people are meeting new people who
would have ever thought Gail right